What is your breakfast or lunch daily? Well, some things I just don't disclose.
So it depends. So if I if it's a work day and I'm going to work typically, I do not eat breakfast.
So I try to do intermittent fasting, but again, I'm not like stick and not a stick to it on anything with that.
If I'm going to be at home and I'm going to be out working in the garden, it's in the summertime and I'm going to be busy.
I honestly, if I'm busy, I just do not have hunger.
And if when I get hungry, it's because I am sitting around not doing anything at home when it's in the middle of the winter.
I tend to put on a weight in the winter and then I lose it in the summer.
So I have about 30 pounds to lose right now. So I am hopeful that, you know, when gardening season starts, which we had some really nice weather, we could go and I got cold again.
I'll be out burning these calories because I just I just will go out work and I'll just work all day outside and my wife and I don't cut it until it's dark and because we just love doing that.
It's sometimes I'll go without breakfast and lunch and I have no problem with that because I need to work calories and that's my intermittent fasting day.
So that's my time restricted eating day, then I'll eat when we get back in the house.
But every day is not the same for me, every day is very different for me. So there's times that I'll eat breakfast.
If we're doing something and we're together, we might have eggs in the winter. I like to eat oatmeal.
But yeah, that's typical breakfast and lunch varies completely.